hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well early on in his proma to any future
metaphysics Emmanuel Kant credited David
Hume with Awakening him from his
dogmatic Slumber and thus leading to the
critical or transcendental philosophy
that will be elaborated in the critique
of pure
reason and in the second part he's going
to bring up Hume quite explicitly and
talk about hume's doubt uh the word
there is Vel right so that can be
translated just fine and has doubt but
we could also say hume's problem the
problem as we often call it of
quality sometimes it's called the
problem of induction the slightly
different matter there but for for Hume
um there's going to be a problem in
making assertions about one thing being
the cause of another
thing and K says well human partly right
so what is Hume correct about says that
Hume justly or rightly MRE right with
with rightness actually uh does maintain
that we can't comprehend in the German
Ein through or by Duke reason F the
possibility of causality and causal is
the German cognant that he is using
there and this you know makes good sense
he he says
um what is going on there the reference
of the existence of one thing to the
existence of another which is
necessitated by the former so
necessitated that's a really key idea
there hum is saying we don't really know
that one thing is the cause of another
because we never grasp that in
experience and we can't derive it solely
by a priori reasoning about that because
all we get from op prior reasoning is
the relation of certain ideas to each
other it doesn't tell us anything about
the reality of the world or the things
in it and Kant is going to in a certain
respect raise the stakes as he did
earlier by saying you know you can
generalize this it's not just qu ality
itself it's also substance and what he
calls Community or G mind shaft of
things so he goes on and he says the
very same
incomprehensibility is going to apply to
uh the concept of subsistence the
necessity that at the foundation of the
existence of things there lies a subject
which cannot itself be a predicate of
any other thing and you know what's he
talking about there
sort of a bottom level of
substance a substratum as Lo called it
um you know subject and predicate here
is kind of Aristotelian ways of thinking
about it but this is you know the
concept of substance that that K is
working with at the time he also then
goes on to say all right the same thing
applies to the community of things we
cannot comprehend how from the state of
one thing an inference to the state of
quite another thing Beyond it and vice
versa can be drawn and how substances
which each have their own separate
existence should depend on one another
necessarily so not only is quality kind
of up for grabs so is substance so his
community and you know if you look at
the tables that he had a little bit
earlier in the work we see that you know
these are Under the relation in the
transcendental tables of the concept of
the understanding substance cause and
community so that's where Kant says that
hum got things right but he says that
where human is going wrong is in going
too far hum is saying that these are not
derived from any experience Kant wants
to say okay they're not derived merely
from any experience that that we have
and they're there you know they're not
Illusions produced by habit as Kant is
going to turn causality into custom or
habit so what is K's solution to this he
says
that I have shown so this is earlier in
the work that they and the principles
derived from them are established a
priori before all
experience and how is he going to do
this this is where in section 28 he's
going to run run through each of these
he says though I have no conception of
such a connection of things in
themselves how they can either exist as
substances or act as causes or St in
community with others as parts of a real
whole and I can just as little think of
such properties and appearances as such
because those Concepts contain nothing
that lies in the appearances but only
what the understanding must think okay
so that's setting up the problem he goes
on and says we have yet
a concept A G of such a connection of
representations in our understanding and
in our judgments generally so let's
pause for a second there what he's
saying is that okay Hume has pointed
something out that's that's quite
correct we're not getting these from
experience we can't just reason our way
to them and yet we do in fact in the
understanding have substance cause and
Community where the hell are we getting
from and the answer has already been
given to us a bit earlier but Kant is
going to go back over this in order to
address hum's problems so he says that
we have a concept or we might actually
want to pluralize this concepts of such
connections of representation for right
things that are presented to us in the
understanding so he says that um
representations belong in one sort of
judgment as subject in relation to
predicates there're substance in another
as ground in relation to consequence
causality in a third as Parts which
constitute together a total possible
cognition Okay so we've got that's
Community all three of these in our
understanding further we know a priori
without considering the representation
of an object as determined with regard
to one or the other of these moments we
can have no valid cognition of the
object if we should occupy ourselves
with the object in itself which we're
not going to do there is not a single
possible attribute by which I could know
it's determined with regard to one or
the other of these moments right
belonging to substance cause or
Community because I don't have any
conception of the possibility of the
connection of uh such such a connection
of existence a connection of the
existence of things in
themselves but he says the question
isn't how things in themselves are
determined we're not talking about that
this is where Hume got things wrong
we're asking about how objects of
experience can and must notice the
possibility and then necessity must be
subsumed under concepts of the
understanding he's already laid this out
for us and he says that I actually get
and so he says if we want to do a test
if we want is a beautiful phrase in
order to put to a test hume's
problematic concept his Crooks metaphys
metaphysic Corum right the uh crisis or
the the uh very center point of this the
concept of cause why are we just doing
cause well because that's what hum was
working with right but we could do this
as well for substance and for community
so we think in terms of condition or as
he's going to call it a little bit later
hypothetical judgment what do we have
when we make a judgment like that if
then if this holds then this holds or if
this exists then this exists and that's
what we typically think of as causing
right but if we're just thinking about
it in terms of the Judgment not
importing the stronger idea of cause we
have an antecedent and a consequent that
we're putting together so you know if it
rains I get wet right we could say well
of course you do because that's what it
means for you know rain to to to be
there it's water it's falling on you
okay great we're just focusing on the
antecedent and consequent at first and
then he says what happens in
perception in perception of things we
meet with a rule of relation which runs
thus here it's going to look a lot like
Hume a certain appearance is constantly
followed by another though not versely
this is a case to use the hypothetical
judgment and say for instance if the sun
shines long enough on a body it grows
warm and he says here there is indeed as
yet no
necessity of connection or concept of
cause now here's where he's departing
from Hume Hume says that's what we mean
by the concept of cause necessary
connection constant connection the fact
that when this happens this thing
happens after that sun shines warms up
rain falls get wet you know light
something on fire it burns we could go
on and on and on and in our real life
right we do encounter all sorts of
empirical connections like that and we
might ascribe causality to them uh Hume
says well you can do that but you're
only doing that because of habit or
custom you're not doing it because
there's anything in experience or
because reason is leading you there
that's the only thing we could do and K
is saying oh no no no wait a second
there's another possibility not just
another possibility but an actuality a
necessity this is how it actually works
so he goes on and he says um such a
proposition uh if we go on to to talk
about this which is merely a subjective
connection of perceptions
if we're going to turn it into a
judgment of experience which he's
already distinguished from judgments of
perception earlier on it must be
regarded as necessarily and universally
valid now Hume could say yeah that's the
problem man you know it's not
necessarily and universally valid you
just think that it is and K is saying oh
no it is we just want to know whether it
actually is that way whether it holds
for us and he
says um the empirical rule is now
considered a law and is valid not merely
of appearances but valid of them for the
purposes of a possible experience which
requires
Universal and therefore necessarily
valid rules and he says I easily
comprehend the concept of cause as a
concept
belonging necessarily to the mere form
of
experience cause is something something
that we are you could say importing
projecting in order to have that kind of
necessity in our
experience experience being not just for
um us as individuals but like he says
Consciousness in general and he says I
do not at all comprehend the possibility
of a thing in general as cause in as
much as the concept of cause denotes a
condition not at all belonging to things
but to experience so um cause substance
Community all these things have to do
with these universally and necessarily
valid rules or laws other principles
coming from them and they're involved in
judgments of experience that we do in
fact make and he says you know you can't
go to the things in themselves those are
the Numa that we'll talk about elsewhere
and he says that um the complete
solution of hume's problem
rescues for the pure concepts of the
understanding their a priori origin and
now notice what he says something he
said a little bit earlier for the
universal laws of nature right so we do
in fact have a physics a natural science
here their validity is laws of the
understanding but in such a way as to
limit their use to experience we cannot
say anything about the causality of the
things in themselves but we sure can
talk about cause and effect in the
phenomenal world that we perceive and
make judgments of experience about
judgments that are not just subjectively
valid for me or you but objectively
valid judgments that apply to any
Consciousness
whatsoever right so he's going to
conclude with something really important
here he says um we have a completely
reversed mode of connection which never
occurred to Hume this is how we resolve
hume's doubt the universal laws of
nature are not deriv from experience we
don't experience a whole bunch of things
and then generalize from them experience
as experience as for K as opposed to
Mere sense perception is itself derived
from the universal laws of nature which
we can discover in this case by
scrutinizing the understanding by
looking at the kinds of judgments that
we do in fact make and according to comp
this leads us out of hume's problem or
hume's doubt it resolves it from the
conscient
perspective